ghostbusters star rick moranis was
sucker punched as he walked down a new
york street
and the brutal attack was caught on tape
this is the shocking moment 67-year-old
moranis was brutally attacked on a new
york city sidewalk
police called the assault a random and
unprovoked act of violence
the incident occurred yesterday morning
at 7 24 a.m
you can see the assailant walking calmly
away moments later
according to police moranis took himself
to the hospital for
head back and hip pain once discharged
he reported the assault to police
his rep tells e.t rick is quote fine but
grateful for everyone's thoughts and
well wishes they're about this big
they're in the backyard
what threw them out with the trash the
honey i shrunk the kids star
has led a low key life since he left
hollywood 20 years ago
recently he made a rare return to the
small screen in a commercial
opposite fellow canadian ryan reynolds
i'm just
a huge fan oh stop it come on don't stop
seriously
massive now to the return of the
controversial series
cops e.t has confirmed the reality show
has resumed production in spokane
washington you've got a warrant
for wax the news comes nearly four
months after paramount network canceled
the long-running series
amidst nationwide protests against
police violence
et has learned these new episodes will
not air in the u.s
but will be broadcast in international
markets where cops still
airs i'm gonna sleep in my car the
spokane county sheriff's office tells
e.t
there are two film crews currently
riding with deputies
they began shooting in september and are
expected to wrap the first week of
november
a e also canceled their similar show
live pd
but in a storyline twist one of the
sheriffs featured on the show
robert chode has now been arrested
chodey was indicted on an evidence
tampering charge for the destruction of
footage
showing officers using deadly force on
40-year-old
javier ambler who died in police custody
i did not tamper with evidence
chodey maintains his innocence and there
is no comment from a
e or former host dan abrams well we know
the sheriff can afford his legal bills
in 2001 he won 85 million dollars in the
texas lottery